madame monsieur bonsoir la montagne si
belle ce soir s'est montré
particulièrement cruel ce matin en effet
cette 15e étape qui s'annonce est épique
et puis l'a été a également été
dramatique avec la chute mortelle ce
matin d'un jeune coureur italien de 25
ans dans la descente du premier col de
portet d'aspet un drame sur lequel nous
reviendrons bien évidemment longuement
au cours de cette édition spéciale et
qui a jeté l'effroi dans toutes les
caravanes dans tout le ton à commencer
par richard virenque le héros du jour
le vainqueur ici à cauterets a au terme
d'une échappée solitaire de 120 km un
exploit formidable qui a confirmé donc
son éclatante santé et son maillot de
grimpeur
cette étape la plus attendue a donc
commencé dans le drame je lisais avec ce
matin la chute mortelle de fabio
casartelli 25 ans champion olympique à
barcelone récit laurent frédéric bollée
immobile est pratiquement déjà sans vie
fabio casartelli j'ai même le sol dans
une mare de sang
à ses côtés d'autres coureurs impliqués
dans une chute terrible on est au 34e km
de la 15e étape du tour de france
au détour d'un virage de la descente du
portet d'aspet le drame a frappé
manifestement l'italien a heurté une des
bornes en béton qui longe la route le
choc le plonge alors immédiatement dans
un coma profond
difficile de savoir ce qui s'est
vraiment passé eca crevaison fautes en
tout cas sans casque sous la chaleur
aujourd'hui casartelli ne se relèvera
pas il avait fêté son 25e anniversaire
il y a deux jours les secours pourtant
sont arrivés très vite
soigné sur place puis évacuée par
hélicoptère casartelli sera victime de
trois arrêts cardiaques pendant son
transfert le décès sera prononcée
officiellement à 14 heures également
touchés dans l'accident l'allemand
baldinger et l'italien périgny souffrent
de traumatismes divers
quant aux français de reins' il a plongé
dans le ravin et s'est blessé gravement
à la cuisse gauche
professionnelle depuis deux ans
casartelli le premier coureur à décéder
sur le tour depuis tony simpson en 67
on se souviendra de lui comme le
champion olympique en titre de la
spécialité en 92 à barcelone il avait
triomphé et avait offert à tous les
observateurs un visage rayonnant à
l'image de sa jeunesse plein d'amis
inutile de dire que ce drame a semé la
consternation dans toute la caravane
sont vous entendre la réaction d'un
chauffeur et d'un commissaire de course
lorsqu'ils ont appris par radio tour la
mort du jeune coureur à l'hôpital
de là-haut jamais bon de prendre le
coeur des rares vie paul et en support
quel rats
quel drame présentant autant
et naturellement le directeur du tour de
france se rendra chez toi je vais pour
un vital si triste vraiment triste
exploités je vous dis aux signatures
voici plus jeunes et côtoie tout ça
c'est à d'urgence était bon et chasse
surtout les étapes de montagne et on
avait une tape amicale tous les voeux et
de mesrine cent par rapport aux
bâtiments jeudi avec moi c'est triste
comme saphir tristement comme ça c'est
si j'ai un but c'est un gars qui avait
un avenir devant lui en guise fabio
casartelli repose maintenant dans une
chapelle ardente a été dressée à
l'hôpital de tarbes où nous pouvons dire
est que patrick chêne une évidence
beaucoup de recueillement beaucoup
dignité ici aussi à celle de tarbes où
une chapelle ardente a été dressée
un paradoxe également car on dit que
c'est la loi du sport mais pas du tout
la mort est révoltante surtout pour un
jeune qui n'a pas encore 25 ans sur la
route du tour de france se sont
recueillis devant la dépouille de fabio
il ya quelques instants le patron du
tour de france jean marie leblanc qui
est arrivé avec jean françois pescheux
avec philippe amaury les hommes se sont
donc recueilli dans cette chapelle
ardente ils ont retrouvé le directeur
sportif de fabio casartelli james orr
vite
hennie kuiper également le directeur
sportif adjoint amy qui a été un grand
champion qui était bouleversé tout comme
james horwill le directeur sportif de
fabio qui était très très touché on s'en
doute alors on se retrouvera en fin de
journal pour faire le point avec cette
équipe
motorola car une question se pose
maintenant l'attitude de cette équipe
demain j'aime sont ravis de ce nous a
dit que les coureurs décideront ils sont
actuellement en réunion ici à trois
kilomètres du chu ils se sont retrouvés
ensemble soudé pour décider si demain
ils repartent en l'honneur de sa bio is
il préfère quitter la course mais tous
nous ont ils dit auront une attitude
commune en tout cas nous on dit et redit
combien fabio était un pion un élément
important dans ce groupe d'une équipe
complètement défaite on les a vu tout à
l'heure très très touché on fera le
point en fin de journal sur l'attitude
de l'équipe demain merci en compagnie de
jean marie leblanc avec lou jean claude
killy président de l'organisation du
tour de france alors bien sûr de tels
accidents sont rares ici montre pour
tous trois coureurs ont trouvé la mort
depuis la fondation du tour de france
depuis la création du tour on dirait que
ces trois trop mais aussi qu'on ne peut
pas imaginer un secours sans risque
il n'en existe pas et nous n'en
connaissons pas nous avons vécu une
journée exceptionnelle parce que il
semblerait bien que les grandes joies
génèrent les grands peine et nous avons
vu une étape exceptionnelle et nous
avons perdu un membre de la grande
famille du tour de france nous nous
sommes également rendus compte nous
organisateurs qu'il n'y a pas moyen de
livrer une course avec risque zéro et
nous sommes également un peu triste de
cela mais nous n'y pouvons rien aux
mêmes vous avez fait du style on le sait
bien et certains gros son qui ont de si
grandes championnes ont trouvé la mort
sur les pistes oui j'ai presque envie de
vous dire assez régulièrement et
notamment qu'un skieur aux jeux
olympiques c'est dieu devant moi en 1964
ça nous a pas empêché de remonter 5,8
après de recommencer parce que nous
pensons que le risque est directement
inscrits dans ce métier que nous avons
choisi que je pense ce cycliste avait
choisi en toute connaissance de cause
tout à l'heure après les informations
énoncées par étienne nerfs nous
reviendrons compagnie jean marie leblanc
et de notre confrère sur les risques
justement pris par les coureurs dans ses
folles descente trouvons vous de tout de
suite retrouvé le héros du jour
richard virenque qui nous attend direct
de son hôtel de tarbes
bonsoir riechers m'entendais tout
simplement richard une réaction ce soir
après ce drame
une réaction c'est sûr que ce qui vient
d'arriver dramatique donc c'est
dramatique ma victoire c'est super mais
ça ça gâche tout tout tout ce que j'ai
fait c'est le sport c'est
le cycliste confessé c'est dangereux et
aujourd'hui ben il ya eu un drame
ma victoire c'est beau mais c'est tout
effacé je pense à la famille du coureur
qui est mort ça doit être sa femme sont
son petite enfance à de dramatiques pour
toute sa famille qui a vu ça en direct
et je les dis un peu ça ma victoire à
ces personnes tout son entourage toute
son équipe sait c'est dramatique et
c'est le tour de france continue mais je
pense qu'il sera en deuil jusqu'à la fin
et mon ma joie et a été vite rabaisser
quand j'ai appris ça c'est ça a fait
drôle merci richard virenque nous
retrouvons après les informations pour
parler justement des risques qui sont
pris par les coureurs tout de suite un
mot avant de rendre l'antenne est une
énarque jean claude arnaud godart oui en
fait si vous voulez je crois que pour
avoir été témoin des 19 derniers tours
de france en tant que journaliste
souvent sur une moto de direct je crois
que ce soir il faut rendre hommage
15h délit qui est décédé mais il faut
rendre hommage aussi en fait à cette
profession à ces professions qui
constitue le tour de france e
pour qu'un tour soit beau pour qu'un
vainqueur soit grand il faut qu'il monte
les cols des alpes il faut qu'il est
descendu il faut qu'il monte les cols
des pyrénées
il faut qu'ils descendent on sait que
pour les descend d'une doit prendre des
risques car tout se joue parfois à coups
de secondes
il y as derrière ces coureurs des
motards qui donne l'image ou monde
entier 130 pays qui assure mia qui lie à
des radios port qui ont été les
reporters et en fait si vous voulez tous
les gens qui font ce métier qui sont
attachés à cet événement du tour de
france vivent une exaltation et quand on
tombe si l'on peut le lendemain on n'a
qu'une envie c'est de repartir
que ce soit pour un coureur ou pour un
motard aujourd'hui malheureusement il ya
décès c'est triste mais n'oublions
jamais je crois ça c'est ça fait partie
intégrante de la vie de d'exact relation
professionnelle de ceux qui sont au
départ de ce tour merci jean rené godart
nous vous retrouvons avec nos invités
dans quelques minutes c'est un énarque
qui va nous donner en direct de paris
les principales informations
on sera bruno madame monsieur bonsoir
nous retrouverons dans une quinzaine de
minutes donc dans l'actualité ce soir à
l'étranger la plus grande confusion
règne dans l'enclavé musulmane de j'ai
pas en bosnie les serbes ont poursuivi
leurs bombardements aujourd'hui et les
forces bosniaques qui défendent la ville
menace maintenant de se retourner contre
les casques bleus et de les utiliser
comme boucliers humains
si l'otan n'intervient par autre
information importante
l'arrivée dans les camps de réfugiés à
tuzla de plusieurs centaines d'hommes
séparés de leur famille au moment de
l'évacuation de srebrenica
les images avec françois corde est une
nouvelle illustration du drame bosniaque
un soldat qui a fui le front de
srebrenica arrive après des jours de
marche à tout cela il vient d'apprendre
l'insoutenable sa jeune femme n'est pas
là il a disparu sur la route enlevé par
les serbes
alors il sert son enfant dans les bras
et ils s'éloignent en silence avec sa
douleur ces deux là ont marché pendant
une semaine à travers la montagne pour
échapper aux serbes
exténué et affamé les pieds en sang les
hommes de srebrenica sont pitoyables
mais ils sont libres dans ce camp de
toile des nations unies près de la base
aérienne des casques bleus à tuzla où
ont été regroupés depuis trois jours
6000 femmes enfants ou vieillards les
hommes rescapés de srebrenica
on retrouvait un peu d'espoir et pour
certains leur famille mais la peur est
incrusté sur tous les visages dans les
yeux hagards de ce qu'ils viennent de
vivre l'enfer
oui je suis cinsault mais j'ai tout
perdu je n'ai plus personne
retour en arrière ces images tournées
par la télévision serbe nous montre la
prise de srebrenica le 11 juillet
les vainqueurs paradant dans la ville
martyre qui porte les stigmates de près
de trois ans et demi de combat les
civils n'ont pas été épargnés les
soldats bosniaques et les volontaires
dont bon nombre d'adolescents qui ont
tenté de résister ont été prises au
piège
encadrés par les serbes ceux-ci
n'arriveront pas à regagner leur ligne
astuce sournoise de la guerre les serbes
oblige un bosniaque a crié aux
survivants de ce rendez vous serez bien
prêter leur dit-il moi j'ai tout compris
transportant leurs blessés ceux qui ne
se rendent pas seront abattus combien
étaient ils à srebrenica 4000 9000 ou
15000 comme l'affirment les autorités
bosniaques
seules quelques centaines seulement ont
pu regagner tuzla et en toute fin
d'après-midi sarajevo la capitale
bosniaque victimes à nouveau de
bombardements bombardement de la part
des serbes selon un premier bilan deux
morts et plusieurs blessés en toute fin
d'après midi donc deux morts deux ans au
delà de l'incapacité de la communauté
internationale à tomber d'accord sur une
éventuelle intervention militaire
un haut responsable ministériel français
sous couvert de l'anonymat affirme
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
bosniaque de sarajevo sa botte
l'installation de la force de réaction
rapide les explications de stéphane
venne mais qui est donc ce mystérieux
hauts responsables ministériels
le quai d'orsay jure ses grands dieux
qu'il ne sort pas de ses rangs ministère
de la défense juge ou la grande muette
mais paris laisse entendre très
clairement que si les propos sont
maladroits ils ne sont pas dénuées de
fondement selon ce haut responsable qui
souhaite rester anonyme
la fédération croato bosniaque c'est à
dire les croates ferait tout leur
possible pour empêcher la force de
réaction rapide d'être opérationnel son
président exigerait quatre jours de
préavis avant tout mouvement de ses
troupes et les soldats devrait décharger
leurs armes avant de traverser chaque
village bref une tracasserie qui aurait
fini par exaspérer les militaires
français
à tel point que toujours selon ce
mystérieux responsable la france
envisagerait une réaction politique
violente si les choses ne changeaient
pas et cet homme d'enchaîner le problème
ce ne sont pas des serbes
mais les bosniaques écouter les
déclarations de mohamed sassi rebelles
le ministre des affaires étrangères
bosniaques à washington hier l'onu a
terminé sa mission date il nous ne
prolongeront pas son mandat après
novembre
il faut lever l'embargo sur les armes
c'est la seule solution
on le voit les croates comme les
bosniaques et 102 pour les raisons
différentes mise désormais tout sur le
départ de l'onu et ils n'ont donc aucun
intérêt à voir la force de rêve
rapide faire montre de la moindre
efficacité mais si paris par le biais
d'une voix unanime fait part de son
agacement
c'est sans doute parce qu'il se rend
compte que sa demande de sursaut ne
suscite guère d'enthousiasmé chez ses
partenaires et qu'il amorce ainsi
discrètement un infléchissement de sa
politique
quoi qu'il en soit les premiers éléments
allemands de la force de réaction rapide
ont quitté la région de francfort à
destination de la croatie mobilisation
également de la croix rouge française
qui lance une opération urgence bosnie à
laquelle vous pouvez participer en
envoyant vos dons croix rouge française
urgence bosnie 94 1944 creteil cedex 9
et un numéro de téléphone
un numéro vert le 05 06 15 15 premières
images officielles du président russe
boris eltsine une semaine après son
hospitalisation pour des problèmes
cardiaques
une interview à la télévision publique
diffusait au journal du soir et vous le
voyez un entretien dans sa chambre
d'hôpital avec son premier ministre
victor tchernomirdine une image qui
rassurera sans doute l'opinion russe
après la forte polémique de ces
dernières heures la seule image de boris
eltsine publié jusqu'à maintenant était
une simple photo prise dans l'hôpital
selon son entourage
mais plusieurs organes de presse
perspicace avait noté une étrange
ressemblance avec un cliché datant du
mois d'avril dernier à moscou dominique
derda bon ici elle signe dit le
présentateur de la télévision russe
poursuit son traitement à l'hôpital
c'est ce que nous a fait savoir le
service de presse du kremlin
cette photo du président de russie
poursuit-il a été prise aujourd'hui on y
voit boris eltsine en chemisette blanche
et bleue assis derrière un bureau
pencher sur ces dossiers avec à sa
gauche quatre téléphones beige et un
rideau gris foncé or cette photo
bizarrement un air de déjà vu
en avril dernier le président russe se
reposait dans l'une des résidences
d'état sur les contreforts du caucase à
l'époque on spécule est une fois encore
sur son état de santé ne venait-il pas
de prolonger de façon imprévue ces
vacances de printemps sur la même chaîne
de télévision un reportage nous le
montrait enfin pour faire taire les
rumeurs
prenons le ferait sur sa terrasse
péchant la truite dans un bassin ou
jouant au tennis tout cela était destiné
à convaincre le bon peuple que boris
eltsine se reposait certes mais qu'il
était malgré tout en pleine possession
de ses moyens
et continuer même à travailler
d'ailleurs tenez on nous le montrait en
chemisette blanche et bleue assis
derrière un bureau pencher sur ces
dossiers avec à sa gauche quatre
téléphones belge est un rite avouer que
la ressemblance est pour le moins
frappante entre cette séquence vidéo
dont voici un arrêt sur image et la
photo prise paraît-il à l'hôpital
le porte parole de boris eltsine affirme
ce soir encore contre vents et marées
que la photo en question a bien été
prises à l'hôpital
certains conseillers du président dans
son entourage ajoute même que yelle
sinem beaucoup les chemisette blanche et
bleue les téléphones beige et les
rideaux grille à croire qu'il ne s'en
sépare jamais ni en vacances ni à
l'hôpital
en algérie les obsèques de l'imam
sahraoui assassiné la semaine dernière
dans sa mosquée à paris funérailles dans
la plus grande discrétion pour le
co-fondateur du front islamique du salut
deux à trois cents personnes en majorité
des membres de sa famille l'ont
accompagné au cimetière sur les hauteurs
d'alger
l'assassinât de deux jeunes israéliens
près de jéricho en cisjordanie ils ont
été tués par balles un attentat que
l'armée israélienne attribue aux
extrémistes palestiniens
et puis un terrible accident d'avion à
madagascar
pardon 34 morts parmi les 40 passagers
d'une mission sanitaire qui venait de
l'île de la réunion l'appareil s'est
écrasé à son arrivée à l'aéroport de
tananarive enfin le dernier bilan de la
vague de chaleur qui a touché les états
unis ces derniers jours 367 mort ce soir
mais les températures en légère baisse
ces dernières heures en france
maintenant la polémique se poursuit sur
l'interdiction de la mendicité à
perpignan le préfet des
pyrénées-orientales ne fera pas
appliquée par la police nationale
l'arrêté pris par le maire de la ville
mendier n'est pas un délit dit le préfet
reportage de philippe boisserie georges
en scène
jusqu'à aujourd'hui les interdictions de
mendicité décrétée par un certain nombre
de maires n'avait engendré qu'un débat
de société
or voilà que la question devient
juridique le responsable bernard bonnet
préfet des pyrénées-orientales
il considère que l'arrêté pris par le
maire de perpignan est tout simplement
inapplicable raison le nouveau code
pénal ne considère plus le vagabondage
comme un délit s'il n'a pas compétence
pour casser l'arrêté du maire il ne
compte même pas transmettre le dossier
au tribunal administratif puisqu'ils
jugent le texte sans fondement juridique
tout le monde ne partage pas son avis je
ne pense pas qu'une telle argumentation
soit soutenable dans la mesure où aussi
longtemps qu'une disposition légale ou
réglementaire n'a pas été abrogée elles
existent au ministère de l'intérieur on
a pris conscience de cet imbroglio
juridique mais pour l'instant rien n'est
tranché la question est à l'étude
en attendant le maire de perpignan
persiste et signe
continuerez pour ce qui nous concerne de
donner des directives à la police
municipale pour traiter aller
discernement les abus constatés
on pourrait donc voir demain dans les
rues de perpignan des policiers
municipaux demandé aux mendiants de
quitter les lieux sous le regard
embarrassé de la police nationale et
puis après la polémique sur
l'interdiction de la mendicité les
propos du ministre de l'intégration eric
raoult font également des vagues il
proposait hier pour ramener le calme
dans certains quartiers d'éloigner les
familles de délinquants une telle mesure
est elle possible et serait-elle
efficace l'enquète à saint denis en
région parisienne de marie pierre farkas
ai-je encore du eric raoult craint les
chaleurs d'été synonyme d'effervescence
dans les banlieues ir il lancé une
nouvelle idée faire déménager les
familles qui sème le trouble dans les
cités s'il est nécessaire
il est important que ces familles
puissent savoir que le bailleur social
c'est-à-dire l'office hlm ou
l'environnement social et bien peu la
sanctionner en la déplaçant d'un des
quartiers vers un autre quartier
pourquoi pas d'une commune vers une
autre commune savez bien souvent une
menace de la sorte c'est mieux qu'une
charge de crs première réaction ce matin
à bobigny préfecture de
seine-saint-denis un million trois cent
mille habitants 180000 hlm et un
directeur de l'office un peu sur plus
est une pratique nous avons depuis des
années nous n'avons pas attendu cette
sujétion pour demander le départ de
famille que l'on considère lourdes ou à
problèmes et qui peuvent perturber la
vie d'une cité monsieur gonzalez est
d'accord pour qu'on accélère les
procédures d'expulsion mais déplacer des
familles d'une seat est une autre c'est
pour lui exporter les problèmes de
voisinage
idriss ravi depuis 20 ans au franc
moisin à quartiers ghettos de saint
denis en cours de rénovation
il s'occupe des petits qui ne sont pas
en vacances et parle de mesures gadgets
ce qui est sûr c'est toujours des faits
vraiment le problème pourrait revoir et
maintenant bon là on essaie de parce
qu'on peut je comprends bien on peut
toujours essayer de rattraper faut pas
baisser les bras mais je continuerai à
gif un peu trop tard pour lui les
enfants des banlieues ne deviendront pas
des caïds si on leur donne des écoles
des maîtres des éducateurs qui savent
simplement se faire respecter
à noter rangs politiques les
applaudissements nourris de michel
rocard aux déclarations du président de
la république sur la bosnie et la
déportation des juifs pendant
l'occupation
dans une tribune au journal le monde
l'ancien premier ministre socialiste
affirme que jacques chirac a su trouver
les mots justes l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire à saint nazaire
depuis 1991 quatre agents de france
télécom sont morts d'un cancer le
syndicat cfdt de l'entreprise met en
cause des produits qui pourraient être à
l'origine de ces décès
l'enquète de notre correspondant jérôme
blanc véronique olive veut aujourd'hui
connaître la vérité
son mari patrick est décédé en septembre
92 des suites d'un cancer comme trois de
ses collègues tous travaillé à france
télécom
au centre de construction des lignes de
saint nazaire on cherche à comprendre
dans la mesure où il avait un cancer qui
est un cancer rare
à son âge il y avait 33 ans et un cancer
dû à l'amiante
or mon mari n'a jamais travaillé
l'amiante donc si ce n'est pas dû à
l'amiante à quoi le cancer at il dit
véronique par l'intermédiaire de la cfdt
a donc décidé de porter plainte contre
france télécom le syndicat met en cause
les produits sur lesquels travaillaient
les agents des manchons de raccordement
certains produits toxiques comme le
styrène entre dans la fabrication de ces
gaines pour la cfdt la manipulation de
ces produits pourraient être à l'origine
de la mort des quatre agents de france
télécom ils avaient entre 31 et 36 ans
nous voulons surtout une étude sur
l'ensemble des produits utilisés et une
étude épidémiologique sur l'ensemble de
france télécom pour savoir si on
retrouve un cas semblable en france
quand on regarde les études de
toxicologie qui elle nous présente des
risques faibles voire nulles dans dans
certains cas on en conclut
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a aucun élément en
faveur d'un rapprochement entre le
travail fait par les agents et les
maladies développées
c'est maintenant à la justice de
trancher le procureur de la république
de saint nazaire a ouvert une
information judiciaire contre x pour
homicide involontaire grève de 48 heures
à air france mouvement des hôtesses de
l'air et des stewards la compagnie
n'assurera demain que 60% de ses vols
moyens et longs courriers
et puis parution au journal officiel ce
matin du décret de privatisation de la
compagnie générale maritime de pechiney
et de renault la première marque de
voitures en france
la privatisation de renault devrait
rapporter 16 milliards de francs à
l'état
l'événement cinématographique de l'été
le retour de batman troisième épisode de
l'homme chauve-souris demain sur nos
écrans nouveaux comédiens nouveau
réalisateur en trois jours aux états
unis le film a battu tous les records
d'entrées
pascal déchets empire moscovitch
nouvel acteur nouveaux costumes beaucoup
plus moulants de là à dire que batman a
fait peau neuve
on pourrait gloser à l'infini sur la
nouvelle lecture proposée par joël
chaulet coeur mais force est de
constater que le nouveau batman a cassé
la baraque partout où il est sorti après
le succès des deux premiers le défi
était de taille mais cette fois batman
n'est plus seul pour la première fois
son partenaire robin qui veut ça casse
de bandes dessinées pour le grand écran
celle qui tend d'ailleurs j'ai été mis à
contribution
r à quoi ça correspond
robin
double pas ce mystère ont formé un duo
mortels je crois qu'il est temps que je
t'aide et la lutte sera sans merci mais
autre nouveauté pour la première fois le
monde saura pourquoi un homme en
apparence normale se déguise la nuit en
force où vit un dilemme personnel qui
n'est pas sans rappeler à l'acteur
choisi val kilmer un autre personnage
qu'il a interprétés mais sur une scène
de théâtre
c'est exactement comme hamlet jeux les
jouets probablement 50 ou 60 fois et ce
rôle continue de me fasciner c'était
parce qu'il ya un aspect totalement
rajic dans leur destin un aspect presque
pathétique quand vous pensez à ce jeune
homme nanti
il a tout l'argent qui le désirent et
pourtant la nuit il va combattre le
crime
il a choisi de le faire enfin choisi pas
vraiment et c'est quelque chose qui
s'impose à lui
on ne vous demande pas pour autant
d'imaginer une lettre en latex
conduisant une amulette mobile mais de
goûter les aventures d'un héros
classiques de notre siècle un héros plus
complexe qu'il n'y paraît un héros
mythique en tout cas pour déjà trois
générations et ce n'est pas fini
voilà il avant de retrouver batman 3
demain sur nos écrans bruno masure tout
de suite en direct de cauterets dans les
pyrénées bruno pour le récit de cette
journée à la fois dramatique et est
superbe
merci en effet la route du tour en de
lier par la mort ce matin d'un jeune
cory italien avec nos invités jean
claude killy jean marie leblanc richard
virenque qui est dans son hôtel et avec
jean rené godart nous reparlerons des
risques pris par ses coureurs sur les
routes au tour de france avec laurent
frédéric bollée tout d'abord récit donc
d'une étape qui avait commencé dans le
drame et qui s'est terminé par un
exploit le peloton s'est élancé une
heure et quart plus tôt au km 34
l'étape qui promettait d'être sublime
devient tragique fabio casartelli chute
avec plusieurs autres coureurs
et c'est la mort qui vient de frapper la
route du tour or c'est au même moment
que richard virenque a étalé ses
prétentions dans la descente infernale
il s'est échappé avec bruno cornillet et
c'est un peu plus tard que le varois des
foules de partir seul
il reste alors 122 km de course au
sommet du peyresourde indurain bien calé
en tête du peloton accuse 2 minutes17 de
retard mais virenque est parti pour un
exploit que la mort de casartelli
empêchera toujours de retenir
à la table du tourmalet claudio capucci
sonne la charge
la chasse aux virenque est ouverte
derrière indurain dessous le rôle côte à
côte les deux premiers du général se
neutralisent
à défaut de fraterniser virenque en tout
cas est en plein coeur de la légende
la foule des grands jours est là et la
flandre est un plaisir qui se mélange
bien à la souffrance de l' escalade
laurent jalabert lui a été lâché 4
minutes 39 de retard au sommet une
dernière descente avant la dernière
montée la plus longue
16 km à 6 % de moyenne bjarne riis le
danois a attaqué et ose défier in du
renne l'espagnol réplique et montre son
appétit
ça n'est pas encore aujourd'hui qu'il va
céder virant tu en as fil de sa
chevauchée fantastique
ces gens ne l'ont pas abandonné il
s'autorise un geste de la main
l'année dernière à luz ardiden virenque
avait déjà bluffé tout son monde
il récidive à cauterets reléguant
capucci à une 17 indurain à 2,54
mais il est impossible de s'en réjouir
en cette journée qui restera son bras
jamais précisément ce drame je vous le
disais à bien évidemment jeté la
consternation milieu du peloton agité
récemment par une polémique sur le port
ou non du casque de sécurité pour nous
d'entendre les réactions de certains
coureurs recueillis par william irigoyen
à manger parce que je suis que la liasse
de minutes je savais pas avant
non
c'est triste
laurent madouas richard virenque laurent
jalabert ils sont tous trouvé leurs mots
pour exprimer leur émotion après le
décès de fabio casartelli
ce soir c'est le problème de la sécurité
des coureurs qui est à nouveau posée et
en particulier le port du casque pour
toutes les étapes un casque que refuse
pourtant de porter les couvreurs depuis
80 ans
il serait peut-être pas mal mais pour
voir si les conditions de la discipline
est tombé
sur l'été la même chose je crois que
malheureusement quand senna situé en
voiture j'en parlerai en formule 1 ces
vélos qui comme ça ça aurait pu être moi
ça aurait pu être un autre changement
parce que je suis passé professionnel il
nous avait obligé le port de casque à
coque rigide savez succès 10 ont suscité
beaucoup de polémiques au sein du
peloton
je crois qu'on est des professionnels on
sent quand on sait qu'au taux doit
porter le casque ou quand on doit pas et
bon ben ça c'est à nous de décider
contrairement à ce qu'affirme l'euro
madouas les coureurs ne sont pas
toujours les seuls décisionnaires
lorsque le tour est passé par la
belgique le port du casque est
obligatoire c'est la règle dans ce pays
il a les tours eux n'ont pas eu à
choisir
nous allons maintenant retrouver en
direct de l'hôpital de tarbes où le
corps de fabio casartelli éveillé par
ses côtés à commencer par l'américain
lance armstrong ancien champion du monde
dont trouvons en direct patrick chêne
oui les équipiers également les chalets
dans les adversaires les coureurs des
autres équipes arrivent tour à tour là
ici dans dans cette chapelle ardente qui
a été dressé donc avec le corps de de
fabio ses équipiers de motorola viennent
d'arriver
actuellement c'est l'équipe chazal qui
arrivent là avec bruno cornillet
notamment et on a vu donc chacun se
recueillir longuement devant la
dépouille alors l'information qui est
intéressante quand même c'est de savoir
quelle va être l'attitude de cette
équipe
motorola et les courants viennent de
sortir d'une réunion philippe visseyrias
était à l'hôtel avec eux il ya quelques
instants il a recueilli donc
l'explication du capitaine de route de
cette équipe durant la séa la romeria
qui termina 3e du tour de france et
alvaro a expliqué à filippi sérias
pourquoi les courants avaient décidé
finalement de continuer ils seront
demain sur leur vélo on écoute alvaro
mejia au micro de philippe
on s'est réunis un moment et on est
arrivé à la conclusion que c'était mieux
de continuer sa famille aussi le
souhaite et il faut le faire pour elle
et pour lui
et les coureurs aussi veulent continuer
oui la majorité des coureurs veut
continuer voilà donc témoignages
recueillis il ya quelques instants
d'alvaro mejia donc le capitaine de
route de cette équipe motorola voilà les
équipes maintenant après l'avoir rejoint
leur hôtel sont en train d'arriver
on voit à bruno cornillet on voit
l'équipe chazal et puis on a retenu dit
tout à l'heure un témoignage meilleure
caméra il n'a pas voulu parler du
compagnon de chambre de fabio alors
qu'en ce moment au au pied de la
dépouille de fabio on retrouve les
équipiers donc de l'équipe motorola qui
se recueillent tour à tour il ya ici une
atmosphère très particulière très je
vais dire à la fois très chaleureuse
très digne car je le répète quand on dit
c'est le sport et bien ce n'est pas le
sport le sport ce n'est pas fait pour ça
il ya à la fois un grand traumatisme
mais aussi une grande dignité
voilà bruno ce qu'on peut dire à
l'hôpital de tarbes où donc repose fabio
merci patrick autres images douloureuses
au celle d'un blessé de la chute de ce
matin l'allemand dire que baldinger qui
est actuellement soigné à saint gaudens
et qui souffre au dernières nouvelles
d'une fracture de l'os iliaque voilà
vous le voyez actuellement sur son lit
de souffrance à l'hôpital de saint
gaudens pour mieux comprendre les
risques pris par les coureurs dans ce
tour de france vous propose des images
tout à fait spectaculaire de la descente
du tourmalet des images filmées ce matin
par notre camarade filles du repos à la
moto il faut le nommer un fils gérard
des images commentées par jean rené
godart or nous sommes dans la descente
de côté ouest du tourmalet le tourmalet
qui culmine
114 m alors cette descente va durer très
exactement pendant 10 km 18 km qui
conduiront les sommes
les coureurs du sommet du col à
luz-saint-sauveur il y à très exactement
sur ces 18 km 1394 m de dénivelé c'est
une descente vous voyez la route la
route est large et en très bon état
c'est une descente extrêmement rapide et
c'est dans cette descente il y a deux
ans que mika ligne dure n a plus de 100
kilomètres/heure avait réussi à
reprendre 53 secondes à tony roaming
heures qui était passé avec le groupe de
tête au sommet du tourmalet
c'est l'un des endroits les plus rapides
que l'on puisse trouver dans les courses
cyclistes dans le monde entier et leur
emploi parfaitement l'état de la
chaussée cette chaussée large c'est une
belle descente qui fait honneur au
cyclisme alors jean claude killy jean
marie leblanc rapidement
qu'est ce qu'on pensait de cette
polémique qui a agité les pelotons
récemment sur le port ou non obligatoire
du casque pourquoi ce qui est valable en
belgique ne l'est pas en france oui
effectivement il ya une polémique vie en
1991 je crois bien d'ailleurs nous
étions dans le tour de france et lui
sait il une en cycliste internationale
avait décrété décidé sa commission
technique que le port du casque
deviendrait obligatoire et les coureurs
n'ont plus ou moins ont plus ou moins
accepté cette décision au mois de mars
au mois d'avril la houle les conditions
atmosphériques ne sont pas trop
exigeante mais lorsqu'il s'est agi le
tour de france en juillet avec la
chaleur avec l'ascension des cols et un
mouvement de rejet et je me souviens que
les coureurs ont fait une grève à pau au
départ d'une étape pyrénéenne d'ailleurs
comme celle d'aujourd'hui et nous avons
été bloqués 20 minutes 25 minutes et
finalement les commissaires de l'uci ont
été contraints de libérer les coureurs
qui n'ont pas porter le casque je vous à
retrouver richard virenque qui est en
direct depuis sa chambre d'hôtel la
table richard est ce que vous nous
entendez est ce que les images tout à
fait frayant que vous avez vus comme des
millions de téléspectateurs ne vont pas
vous incitez demain à mettre un casque
tout simplement savez on prend tous le
risque de pas mettre le casque passe
quand il fait chaud vous monter un col
et il fait plus de 35 degrés dans le col
vous avez une lanière autour du cou qui
vous empêche à moitié de respirer donc
c'est difficile je pense que chacun doit
être libre savoir s'il prend le risque
qu'il ne prend pas mais il faut pas
faut voir aussi si la chute si la mort
plutôt a été causée 104,6 le casque et
il aurait eu sur la tête peut-être il
serait aussi morts donc je pense que
chacun on prend le risque qu on le prend
pas et on est majeur et vacciné gérer
pour pour dire si on se sent en sécurité
avec le casse - des fois quand je sens
que ça craint eh ben je met le casque il
ya des casques ça c'est les cases deux
contre un monde pour être plus
performant c'est à dire au niveau du
temps mais bon en efficacité
c'est sûr si un choc sur la tête c'est
amorti mais si c'est un choc faciale il
risque de mourir donc vous savez comme
je le dis on prend tous le risque qu'on
prend tous des risques on peut tomber
dans un ravin dans une descente
on sait que c'est dangereux le vélo et
voilà mais ces moments dramatiques ce
qui arrive aujourd'hui dans le tour de
france
merci richard d'un mot jean claude killy
bon c'est sûrement très pénible pour les
coureurs mais si tous avaient à ce
problème d'un casque qui leur donne
chaud et qui les étrangle un petit peu
ils seraient tous à égalité
boudet je pense que le matériel va
certainement évoluer et que rapidement
on construira des casques qui
permettront de respirer et aussi d'avoir
cette sécurité supplémentaires je trouve
dommage que que tous ne décide pas de
mettre un casque et qu'on en parle plus
parce que ces crèmes la tête qu'il faut
protéger d'abord et on parle d'un métier
vraiment dangereux commandant comment
parle de danger dans les autres sports
de vitesse on s'aperçoit quand on voit
cette descente du tourmalet qu qu'on
passe d'un côté à l'autre de la route
qui a des précipices qu'il ya des des
bornes en béton et des arbres tout le
long et que que ce mot gêne je trouve ça
un peu dommage
fort heureusement ces accidents mortels
sont tout à fait rarissime sur le tour
de france depuis sa fondation trois
coureurs seulement ont trouvé la mort
tom simpson en 67 mais c'était pour des
raisons de dopage bien connu en 1935 un
coureur espagnol nommé cepeda était
tombé dans un ravin du côté de bourg
d'oisans mais ils ont la vue
et on l'a revue de très nombreux
accidents graves ou spectaculaires
notamment luis ocaña en 71 vous propose
un petit rappel de ces accidents a signé
jacques cardoze 1967 lendemain du drame
aucun coureur ne manifestera un esprit
de compétition respect du défunt la
veille en effet le tour connaissait
l'une des pages les plus noires de son
histoire
tom simpson hésitant fatigué épuisé
vacille et tombe dans la montée du
ventoux
le britannique est victime d'une
défaillance cardiaque
il n'a plus que quelques minutes à vie
mais déjà en 53 les actualités
françaises nous rappellent d'autres
chutes qui a fait une chute vertigineuse
de 30 mètres dans le ravin à l'endroit
où ça démarre année s'il ya deux saisons
les opérations de sauvetage s'organise à
son tour le champion helvète hugo koblet
victime d'une défaillance tombé dans la
descente du soulor et que dire de cette
année 71 ocaña est en jaune il
rivalisait domine pour la première fois
eddy merckx
on est dans la descente du col de mente
il manque un virage percute ce domaine
sous l'orage dans la boue ocaña est à
terre le tour est terminé le duel merckx
ocaña est dramatiquement achevée
prématurément
et si aujourd'hui il y à une meilleure
préparation des organismes tous
redoutent encore ces moments tragiques
de l'épopée du tour reste que la
défaillance parfois mortelles fait bien
partie du salaire de la sueur
jean rené godart demain le tour continue
d'ailleurs les équipiers de motorola
seront sur la ligne de départ à tarbes
oui je pense que les 3800 personnes qui
constituent la caravane du tour de
france qui constituent l'ensemble de
cette organisation partiront comme les
gens de motorola en pensant à casartelli
au moment du départ mais ensuite à la
poursuite de cette compétition il reste
cinq étapes jusqu'à paris il y à deux
mains une belle étape des pyrénées entre
tarbes et pau il y a un maillot vert
laurent jalabert qui était intense est
insolent depuis le départ il y à charge
virale porteur du maillot blanc à pois
rouges miguel indurain qui va peut-être
dans cinq jours
égaler le record dans t-il de merckx et
dino de victoires dans le tour le tour
de france continue on parle souvent dans
le spectacle the show must go on le
spectacle continue
je pense que pour le tour de france
c'est la même chose et le meilleur de la
meilleure manière pour nous tous de
rendre hommage au corps qu'à 10 sport
aujourd'hui c'est de continuer demain et
qu'il y ait une belle course et que le
cyclisme soit de nouveau peu apprécié à
part des centaines de millions de
téléspectateurs
je crois que c'est ça le message que
veut faire passer d'eux merci jean rené
godart demain donc étape de tarbes pau
avec à nouveau un direct à 13 heures et
à 20 heures sur france 2 jours non
directive au tout simplement de nous
quitter sur l'image de ce champion un
fabio casartelli 25 ans qui participait
à son deuxième tour de france un
champion tout à fait prometteur et qui
laissait éclater sa joie lors de sa baie
die olympique à barcelone en 92
fabio casartelli qui nous a quittés ce
matin sur une petite route des pyrénées
c'est à lui que ce journal a été dédiée
bien sûr je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée